Unsurprisingly, interoperability of medical devices is a challenge,
both within and outside of hospitals.
A 2012, Association for the Advancement of Medical Instruments,
AAMI survey of 1,900 US hospitals,
found that interoperability issues were first and
second on the list of medical device challenges.
Specifically, they were integrating
medical devices and systems into the hospital's network,
which was cited by 72% of respondents.,
and integrating device data into EHRs,
which was cited by 65% of respondents.
When we looked at Health For you saw a plethora of devices used by patients,
each of them typically has its own proprietary data formats.
So Health For provided value by bringing that data together in one record,
along with other data collected from EHRs or documented by the patient.
In the past the vice data was often available only
via a portal maintained by its manufacturer.
And there might have been a charge to use it.
Continua Health Alliance founded in 2006,
is an international non-profit open industry group
of nearly 240 healthcare organizations and vendors.
Its goal is to establish mHealth interoperability in three major categories,
chronic disease management, aging independently,
and health and physical fitness.
Personal Connected Health Alliance is a non-profit organization
formed by the huge Healthcare Information and Management Systems Society HIMSS,
Continua, and the mHealth summit to bring together stakeholders to quote
realize the full potential of personal connected health end quote.
It now publishes and promotes the global adoption of
continuous open mHealth interoperability framework.
Human API and Validic are two interesting companies that have each developed
an interoperability platform for mHealth data from a wide variety of sources,
aimed at both patient care and wellness.
Both offer rest APIs to access their normalized data in JSON formats.
I have posted links to their sites where you can see how this works.
Note, that the results may come back in a JSON format,
but not yet in an industry standard format.